[Music]
hey guys welcome to the feel good
podcast congratulations
[Music]
chris everett check that remember that
[ __ ] with jim rome dude
we talked about that on this podcast
before go figure out guess what episode
who knows who knows man we've talked
about so much [ __ ] um
it is episode
223 of congratulations
the world famous
uh
uh feel-good podcast of the century dude
isn't that great yay
yay the feel good podcast of the century
yay
anything feel good [ __ ] sucks he's a
hater my babies he's a hater i don't
like feel good you know i was talking
about how dessert sometimes is too
deserty and somebody said this man will
hate on anything and it's not that it's
the sweetness it's the sweetness if it's
too sweet i'm out things need to be
deluded otherwise
you keep going you keep banging and
banging and banging and banging and
banging and banging and before you know
it you're eating a mcgrib and you're
liking it you can't be liking it you
can't be liking a mcrib you know why
cause mcgribs are absolutely [ __ ]
atrocious and if you like mcgrib you
piece of [ __ ] now that's over on the you
could go see me uh on the on my second
youtube channel more christilia and uh
where i just put out a mcrib thing
uh where i'm [ __ ] uh evaluating the
piece of [ __ ] mcrib and then i also have
a new video out uh where i'm baking a
pie and i [ __ ] killed that pie dude i
made a pie so good i had my daddy and my
mommy eat it dude and guess what
happened they said hey guess what chris
you gotta make two pies for thanksgiving
[Music]
dude how gangster is that your boy
didn't know he was a pie maker
your boy didn't know he was a baker dude
what the [ __ ] what do i have what do i
what am i a character in a lifetime
movie
[ __ ] in a lifetime movie said it with
the wrong accent and the sentence was
done before way before i thought it was
in a lifetime movie in a lifetime movie
what am i a character in a lifetime
movie dude that's the kind of [ __ ]
mother dude i gotta i'm whatever dude i
made two pies i made one pie i'm gonna
make two buys for thanksgiving this
episode will be after thanksgiving but
the pies will be [ __ ] fantastic man
the first part made was fantastic
anyway dude go get your merch at
crystalia.com we got the new life rips
set out uh we've got the new by the way
the sandstorm [ __ ] that's all it's like
it's going every time i restock it that
[ __ ] flies off the shelves chrisleya.com
i'm so sorry to break your heart strong
guys we've got that merch we've got the
uh uh make friends in the comments merch
and that [ __ ] is mint green it's just so
drippy you guys
it's so drippy
we've got short sleeves long sleeves
we've got pants dude we do it all man
and we've got mugs too we've got life
rips mugs out there crystalia.com that's
the newest thing um and i'm drinking
from the me right now
um mug from matalia
he sells those
um so yeah um
so that's what's up dude i i just i i
gotta keep saying this because people
aren't really understanding what i'm
saying like i try to get the message out
here
by using this podcast my platform
hundreds of thousands of people watch
this [ __ ] i mean we have episodes that
go up into the millions
i'm trying to [ __ ] tell you guys
i'm not watching [ __ ] succession okay
i'm not watching it this is for my
friends for my family for my fans i'm
not watching it don't tell me to watch
it you don't have to tell me how good uh
uh episode five was this season that it
might be the best uh episode of the
whole i'm not watching it i don't do
that
and if i didn't watch squid game as
early as i did i wouldn't watch that
either dude okay your boy found squid
game real early on
i found squid game
way early on dude you know why because
i'm not racist dude i'll watch anything
they don't have to be speaking english
they don't have to all be white
all of those people were korean in that
and i watched it before i knew it was
some hot [ __ ]
okay now everyone's going on and on
about korean [ __ ] about you gotta watch
this you gotta watch that and guess what
watch some other korean [ __ ] after that
because everyone was like oh yeah if you
like that you gotta watch this and guess
how bad it was
so bad
squid game is good the other stuff that
people say is better well actually well
actually if you like squid game you
actually got to see you know what you
should see you got to see the one with
the no it's
bad the new show hellbound on netflix
that the guy from trader busan made it
is bad
i didn't [ __ ] make these rules
right
i didn't make these rules
but the thing is
bro there's too many shows to watch i
don't watch them when they come out
i'm in control of my body and i'm not
[ __ ] watching tv shows here's here's
the thing
the world created binge watching thank
you world so that's it now i get the
binge watch oh you [ __ ] you want
me to tune in
to weekly television
what is this 1994
what am i trying to watch a [ __ ]
commercial dude
i'm watching i'm binging that's it you
created binging i don't i don't go
backwards
oh yeah but you got to watch success oh
cool oh where do i watch it well um yeah
actually it comes out uh every every
week it comes up stop right there stop
right there dude
i wait till all of the [ __ ] is done and
it's dumped on the hbo max and then i
can watch it but guess what i don't
watch it right afterwards i don't do
that because some shows are banging and
then drop the [ __ ] off and then i'm
caught in the middle right
i wait years after this [ __ ] the show
has to hold it has to stand the test of
time breaking bad i saw that in 2020.
you know how gangster that is i wait i
wanted to watch it but i wait
i saw lost in 2020
i saw dexter five years after dexter i
wait
because the last thing you're doing is
getting me on the [ __ ] hype train and
clicking on [ __ ] oh homeland's good
cool oh middle of season one amazing oh
this is a [ __ ] banging show oh
homeland season two
i'm out
right remember when everyone was up and
you got to watch home they got one up
and then season 2 of homeland everyone
was going like this
uh so anyway there's another show called
24 then i don't dude i'm not getting
caught in the middle of that [ __ ]
the show will be the whole show every
episode will come out and then your boy
will try to binge watch it but just not
yet though
it has to stand the test of time the
wire i watched it way later sopranos i'm
still not done with it that's how
gangster i am
do you understand
talk about a show after then i'll watch
it
the good ones that's great make the show
make the whole show
make the whole show take a break
let the society figure it out nobody
talks about homeland i wouldn't have
[ __ ] even thought about homeland
right now
i'll never watch it
didn't stand the test of time season one
was good season two was all right
whatever i don't know how far it went
but that was all the rage dude you
didn't trick your boy i didn't get
caught dead in the middle of homeland no
[ __ ] way dude no way
you created binge watching so now i
binge watch i [ __ ] up and i put on the
dexter new dexter thing true blood i
thought it was a movie and then [ __ ]
it's one
they're like next it next week i'm like
oh for [ __ ] sake i thought it was a
movie and now i've realized that there's
going to be like 10 episodes of the
[ __ ] [ __ ] and i'm stuck this [ __ ]
better be good to change the intro
remember the [ __ ] intro used to be
like
and now it's all [ __ ] slick and [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] with a good thing
so that's that's my you know my thing
about the binge watching thing stop just
stop telling me how good succession is
i'm not gonna but you really okay i know
you have a thing but your religion my
friends will be telling me this
and mark wahlberg stop you're done you
did it you did it dude
what's with the clo he's got a clothing
line now
why for what dude this is what i don't
get
about these uber successful
[ __ ] i get that it takes a
certain mentality to get but mark warbur
dude the rock like when he's tequila
really
ah
you know
tequila
kevin hart you're making underwear
mark wahlberg is making [ __ ]
what are you doing kevin hart what are
you doing with your law network you know
what i mean like what do you what's the
end goal to be a kadrillionaire
they just don't stop
mark wahlberg has a clothing line mark
wahlberg has a clothing line
what's it called municipal or some [ __ ]
i could
don't have don't ever get the municipal
clothing we got the sweats we got the
tops good for working out
for what what the [ __ ]
does mark wahlberg have a clothing line
for
hey man
you're in four brothers
chill on the crew necks
you know
hey dude
you're in transform you're not even
transformers one you're in transformers
four
cell on the sweat pads
i don't get it
why because i ca because i can i think
that's the thing it's like because i can
like rappers i get it you're you know
rappers dress like [ __ ]
lunatics but mark wahlberg just puts on
a shirt and jeans every day
you know i wanted to come i wanted to
come correct because like another look
the good cut
fashion designers good the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] uh
you know i don't like the cut of the
shirt and then you
wall burgers
oh you make
you make
burgers dude
hey mark wahlberg you don't even eat
burgers look at your body and dude now
you're going to chill out in your
clothing line eating your burgers dude
[ __ ] wall burgers
it's a play on words
like just did it because it's the play
on words dude
you can't have a company that although
it's successful who the [ __ ] am i doing
now who the [ __ ]
wahlburgers dude they're good as [ __ ]
have you ever had a wall burger god damn
dude
they're good as [ __ ] i'm gonna get some
municipal clothings
yeah but mark wahlberg what's the end
game here
you're going to be the president you
know
dude you know the rock is running for
president right you know the rock is
running for brother if if the rock
dude
if the rock
doesn't
run for president i will stick a turkey
baster
full of gasoline up my anus and sit down
are we good i will do that
if the rock dies
of rag of you know of old age you can't
get hit by a car because i was like you
know people could come up well he didn't
run and he did die so technically here's
the gasoline with the turkey base or go
sit on it if he dies of old age
and doesn't run for president yeah i'll
probably be if that does happen i'll
probably be 65 or something
i'll remember remind me dude
if i still have this [ __ ] show shoot
me but remind me
i'll do it there's no [ __ ] way dude
you got to know people man
you think the rock isn't gearing up for
a 20 no a 2032 election you're out of
your goddamn mind
you know how the simpsons predicted
everything this show is predicting
everything from here on out
the rock 30 32 20 32 30 32 hello vote
for me i am i am the rock
i died 1 000 years ago
yeah dude the rock that's it oh he's
gonna win
can you smell what the president's
cooking
just getting drunk off his tequila
wearing municipal shorts mark wahlberg
is his vp
you know i really think though just
getting behind the rock was really the
idea to go
um
as a matter of fact dude that's gonna be
what it is that's a ticket the rock and
mark wahlberg president vp
2032. um
yeah
these guys when do they stop kevin hart
he was in a feel-good movie with [ __ ]
brian cranston when does it stop dude
oh [ __ ] when i start doing movies dude
forget it that's it that's it
i'm gonna do the crazy i'm gonna be in a
lifetime movie dude i will be in a
hallmark movie i will be in [ __ ] days
of our lives i'll do all sorts of crazy
janky [ __ ] and i'll also do that good
jet
guys are doing it all wrong man i don't
get it
yeah i got a neck tattoo dude that's
what's up
it's real put the [ __ ] put it let's
put it to bed dude it's real
i loved it my i posted it on my
instagram and everybody there were so
many people like you could tell it's
fake bro yeah right you can tell it's
fake look at the third pick you can tell
it's fake what about this what about how
it's real though it's real dude i'm all
in you lean in
you lit in
i don't give a [ __ ] for the longest time
i wasn't getting tattoos i always wanted
tattoos for the longest time i didn't
get tattoos because you know i was like
well i don't have to cover it up for
jobs or this and that i don't want to
distract it from my stand-up i don't
give a [ __ ] look at it look at it all
day long i don't care
i love it i love it
i had a little bit of a [ __ ] as soon
as i got it i started driving home and i
was like oh my god what did i do and
then [ __ ] five minutes later i was on
dude it hurt like a [ __ ] you
know what people say do neck tats hurt
because it's your neck and it's a
sensitive area you know think about it
think about when someone kisses you're
like
right think about like that second time
you're starting to like make out with
the chick and then she's like goes for
your neck and you're like
like it's a real sensitive area right
like if you're ever
i don't know it seems like a two like if
you're if you're kissing
with someone you know whether you're a
guy or a girl and you're kissing a guy
or a girl like the first time if they're
going for the next [ __ ] that's a little
much right but the second time if you're
going for the next [ __ ] okay because
we're a little bit more familiar with
each other right
it's a sensitive area you don't want to
go to that sensitive area right away
right what if they don't like it so
the second time you go for that scentsy
area right and so that's what that's
what you're doing so the neck is a
sensitive area so when i get the [ __ ]
neck tattoo i was like it's gonna hurt
and the guy's like yeah it's gonna hurt
as much that's the thing about tattoos
for those of you who don't have tattoos
they hurt as much as you think that they
would hurt but there's something that
they don't tell you and i'm gonna get
into that okay now this tattoo took
about two and a half hour two two and a
half hours
it didn't take that long i was thought
it was gonna take a long time most of
the time it took was him drawing it out
um
um i'll shout out the guy afterwards but
uh so i wanted to get this 40 with the
rose coming through it right
uh there's 40 days between all of my
family's birthdays like it's very weird
and coincidental uh calvin was born
february 18th uh
20 to 18 20. add all that up together
it's it's 40. a lot of 40 40 was a
transformative year in my life a lot of
things are connected a lot of
connectivity with the number 40 in my
life so i was like oh [ __ ] this is gonna
be a banging tattoo and i decided to get
it and
i'm happy about it all right
but i wanted to do that i wanted to
demean something because it's on my
[ __ ] neck right i don't want to get
the goddamn roadrunner or whatever the
[ __ ]
my friend when in high school one time i
was in when i was in high school we were
at the ymca working out and he had a
[ __ ] yosemite sam on his ankle and he
[ __ ] got and it got like caught in a
car accident and yosemite sam was like
all jagged and [ __ ] and he was like the
only thing that makes a yosemite sam uh
tattoo worse is a scar in between his
[ __ ] goddamn mustache it looked awful
but it was hilarious anyway so i'm
sitting down like how much it's gonna
hurt and he drew it out it took two
hours he drew it out and then it and
then i sat down he's like it's gonna
hurt you're gonna
you know it's gonna hurt as much as you
think it does
first hour
i realized something oh
i must be a tough guy
it doesn't hurt at all
it's sensitive right
but it doesn't hurt at all oh i realized
oh good thing i'm getting this neck
tattoo
because i'm a tough guy
because it doesn't hurt at all and like
these [ __ ] out here say tattoos
some people say oh did it hurt dude this
didn't hurt this didn't hurt i got one
in my chest it doesn't hurt i have one
right around my anus
i don't but it just doesn't hurt right
an hour in no pain i'm like oh
i guess i'm a tough guy i always
wondered you know
i haven't been in that many fights or
anything like that
but i always wondered if i was a tough
guy and right now the first half of this
neck tattoo i'm realizing oh [ __ ]
good thing i'm a tough guy
the second hour of the neck tattoo i'm
not gonna lie
it started hurting
now i realize it was because you know
the first hour he was [ __ ]
opening it all up and then when he was
going over it he was going over it again
and it was opened all the [ __ ] up and he
was just
to the already tender area so now i'm
less of a tough guy but i'm like i could
deal with it
15 minutes into the second hour we're
about an hour and 15 minutes in
it it feels
annoying but my it wasn't the pain it
was the fact that my body was like
hey
get out of here
what are you doing though
my body was going like this
[Music]
so
hey it's really uncomfortable um
[Music]
it was like a next door neighbor and the
party's too loud it was just
hey just i'm trying to sleep it's past
10 and
honestly your hubba stink is too loud
and if you could just turn it down i'd
appreciate it that's what my body was
doing
imagine that then for 45 minutes dude my
body wanted my body was like what are
you just just get away from what's
happening
and it wasn't the pain
it was the
amount of uncomfortability my body was
in laying there just having to sit there
and do something that wasn't pleasant
and my legs were twitching i was
breathing heavy and i was like
ah it was so [ __ ] annoying dude and
when he finished oops i leveled up
when it finished oops i leveled up
right
i walked into that parlor
a certain amount of sexy
and then when i walked out
i was top-notch sexy whoops i leveled up
right
i walked down the street different now
okay
your boy's got something crazy about him
i'm super mysterious why would crystalia
get an uh oh that's just how it is
it's different now
so when you look at me you see my face
but you also see 40.
it's a little different now
i'm all in dude
these [ __ ] are out here you
know oh you're hardcore okay well i got
a [ __ ] 40 and a rose on my neck so
it's all good
that's how hardcore your boy be
i'm gonna get more dude i'm gonna i'm
lucky you're lucky if i don't get a
[ __ ] eagle around my throat
i don't know man
um
[ __ ] wall burgers you know
there's a new um what do you call it
uh
um
what do you call it a
website social networking
website called
space hay
have you heard about this
one
space hey dude
it's a on this
oh we did okay dude space hey it's a
[ __ ] throwback to like the retro days
of like myspace it looks just like
myspace it's called space hay
okay
the worst [ __ ] name first of all call
it hey space
space hey
what kind of [ __ ] down syndrome [ __ ]
is that space hey
hello space hey
that's like if a down syndrome dude was
in a rocket near mars you're like you
know where we are space hey
[ __ ] it cancel me i don't give a [ __ ]
that's what it's like dude space hey
space hey dude
dude
hey
should never be the second [ __ ] word
in your thing you know
if you are walking or if mark walks into
a room mark hey you've been doing some
shady [ __ ]
hey mark that's nothing mark hey you
were [ __ ] mark's wife
okay
mark's house is on fire
mark hey you just [ __ ] lost mark's la
you know [ __ ] the
stocks i'm taking less gabapentin now so
i can remember words yes dude i'm
thinking let's get my pentane yes
his legs are fidgety but he's still
busting and keeping it real
so
um yeah dude so i do
so so so space taste so it's called
space hay and it's four
[ __ ] absolute losers
space has for [ __ ] losers and it's
because dude just give it up you know
what i mean myspace was a thing it came
and went then you got facebook it came
and went now your grandpa and grandma's
all on facebook that's fine give it up
instagram is a thing and it's slowly
becoming nothing and now it's tick tock
whether you like it or not but guess
what it's not space hey dude it's not
okay
who's on it [ __ ] 60 year olds
so [ __ ] so ruthlessly sad to be on
[ __ ] space hey
how many people are on space hey what do
they have like a [ __ ] hundred
thousand people that's hilarious
just a hundred thousand people in
[ __ ]
jinko jeans
um
we gotta watch this [ __ ] video dude
we gotta watch this video right here
this guy this video is so [ __ ] funny
kid gets hit in a crotch moans and farts
all of the things i like all of the
things i like in a video dude and how
long is the video oh dude it's [ __ ]
12 seconds oh dude it's not even time
out of my day i watched it countless
times dude look at this kid figuring
this [ __ ] out
i have a question does anyone know how
to actually use these things because
i seriously have no idea
oh
dude i have a question does anyone know
how to actually use these things because
i seriously have no idea
oh dude why is he bust man
why is he [ __ ] bust
snap oh
wettest fart dude
wettest fart dude what a [ __ ] wet
garbage fart
i have a question so does anyone know
how to actually use these things because
i seriously have no idea
oh
bro
keeps farting at the end dude
[ __ ] falls down in the farts like
we're not done
oh my god
[Laughter]
i have a question how come does anyone
know how to use these things because
nobody
i just seriously don't sp
oh
just
so
sad there's no there's nothing worse
that's ever gonna happen to this person
you know dude the [ __ ] little closet
he's in that's in 19 million [ __ ]
homes in california dude the [ __ ]
goddamn look at this [ __ ] i have a
question
does anyone know how to actually use
these things because
i seriously have no idea
just a dying animal dude
just a deer that got shot i have a
question does anyone know how to use
these things because
i have seriously no idea
dude the worst
sounds that have ever been all together
dude
imagine busting and [ __ ] like that
holy [ __ ] man why is he bust man
guys got a pain kink for sure
god damn that's hilarious
oh [ __ ] that [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
dude did you know that 1.2
of people in america are schizophrenic
huh
oh dude i didn't know that
oh figure out schizophrenia doctors
oh that's too many
1.2 peop 1.2
of people in america
think that there's
like basically 1.2 more americans
do you know what i mean that's insane
schizophrenia is that thing where you
think other people are around you how
many people do schizophrenic people
think are in america how many people are
in america by the way
like five hundred thousand four hundred
thousand
i'm sorry uh how many
yeah
three thousand three thousand people
three three hundred million
oh for [ __ ] what would i say three
hundred i meant 300 million god damn it
[ __ ] [ __ ] i i'm still taking
gabapentin
how many people are in america 330
million okay [ __ ] that's so many
people to have schizophrenia
how many people is that to have
schizophrenia
30 million people
330 million people
30 million people come on
what is it
39 million people hell yeah dude that's
way too many people to have
schizophrenia
right
oh saying hang on the worst
mathematician and he has an ipad right
in front of him one fire one fire dude
whatever it's a lot of people do it i
don't need to know skin is a friend dude
that is so many people that think that
there are so many more people than there
actually are that that is so sad
how many
oh this is a [ __ ] debacle this is a
travesty how many [ __ ] 4.8
4.8 million people no it's more than
that dude it's 30 million people it's
gonna be 30 million for [ __ ] sake dude
yeah i i wish you had microphones at
this time point so i could just so we
could talk but we can't do it it's a
solo show we keeps it real we keep it
that way dude okay anyway dude cut a lot
of that [ __ ] out by the way but um
dude
i mean so many mistakes were made there
god damn so many [ __ ] mistakes i said
330 000 people were in america
i meant million i thought i was saying
million i have gaba but dude i have a
[ __ ] goddamn i need to i need to get
this guy i could need to wean off my
kept repentance
but anyway dude my point is that there's
too many people that have schizophrenia
and it's not even [ __ ] interesting
anymore i was gonna go on a whole thing
and i just don't even care about it
anymore but that's the beauty of this
podcast yes dude some [ __ ] topics
crash and burn ah yes
[ __ ] yeah dude
oh
how many [ __ ] what i want to know for
real is
how many [ __ ] spider-man movies are
there
first of all
i saw the new movie coming out called
tick tick boom boom or whatever the [ __ ]
it is with that guy who plays
the first the second spider-man what's
his name uh
andrew garfield okay dude it's a movie
where he uh plays a piano and sings and
i don't like when all of a sudden actors
were just going to sing throughout the
whole movie you know like when you and
mcgregor did it in moulin rouge
all of a sudden he was you were just
like okay i guess he sings i don't know
you know
and now [ __ ] andrew garfield's doing
it in a movie called tick tick boom
worst title of all time all good right
people will watch it anyway because
andrew garfield because netflix all good
from the creators of [ __ ] uh
lumen manuel whatever that guy's name is
all good doesn't matter i feel that's
fine my point is
there was a [ __ ] billboard on it that
said
uh
um
urgent performance by andrew garfield
that was the thing they used to put on
the billboard urgent performance dude
like like like the the [ __ ] sucking
balls that these [ __ ] that
these critics
did just say it's great
these critics try to come out with so
many different ways to say how
something's good this is so
urgent before get up now by the way it's
streaming go now this is important when
they see people say an important but an
important portrayal by
the [ __ ] chick that's in the goddamn
new men in black movie that chick is
always the [ __ ] darling right now
right
the the lady with the who was in the i
don't even know she was in black mirror
and then she was all of a sudden in 900
hollywood and things and now she's doing
a movie in black and white i don't even
know her name it doesn't matter i never
want to know it but it's just like
a gut-wrenching ripping performance
they're just saying urgent performance
what do you mean it's on netflix i could
just watch it whenever
an urgent prof they don't even give up
they're just saying [ __ ] this movie is
an unbelievable ferrari
it's just [ __ ]
just just just say it's great dude your
job isn't a job
the most urgent performance in the last
decade dude he's singing playing the
piano saying tic tic boom boom
he's [ __ ] spider-man for [ __ ] sake
dude what's the [ __ ]
how many spider-man movies are there is
what i'm getting at
how many 900
how many
how many spider-man movies are there and
who's spider-man now
i'm 41 who's spider-man now there's all
sorts of [ __ ] playing
spider-man every [ __ ] five years and
it's like it's the new james bond and
then how many and why is it always hey
spider-man comes home spider-man back
home home home homecoming spider-man
home slice spider-man the home slice
shut up intel's
[ __ ] butter shut up
the anger comes out
how many [ __ ] spider-man
shut up
god i hate my [ __ ] i love my dogs i
never think about them
spider it's like
my favorite spider-man was andrew
garfield i'm the only guy who doesn't
think that he's the [ __ ] good
spider-man
what's his name toby maguire just sucks
because he's just
dude spider-man's gotta be a little bit
good-looking toby mcguire is just a guy
you would walk past
in
ohio
you know what i mean you just walk past
them and someone would be like did you
see that guy and you'd say no
that's who toby maguire is
anybody's name
also dude
like your name is toby you know
what is this [ __ ] are you kidding me
this movie review tick tick boom boom on
netflix watch an itchy urgency
when an itchy urgency needs some
scratching this is the [ __ ] goddamn
[ __ ]
it's just a movie dude you know it's not
voting
these these critics are the worst all
critics every critic you know
why why are we making them have a job
they don't
it's one of those [ __ ] non-jobs
like i always say like hitch
on [ __ ] uh
with will smith that's not a job
um
but what was i talking about uh
uh spider-man dude i mean
it's just like
and then the tom holland is that his
name oh i love that kid i love that guy
that dude just always like spoiling
movies and [ __ ] that he's in
he he completely spoils every movie he's
in doing uh
doing a
uh promo for it
but he's just uh he's pushing it he's a
good actor he's a [ __ ] great actor
but just like spider-man was andrew
garfield to me dude he's handsome but
also seems like he might be an aloof
dork that's who [ __ ] peter parker was
that's it dude i don't talk about it
anymore i'm done i'm done talking about
that there's 900 spider-man movies
i played a little gta and i'm trying to
get into it but it's no red dead
redemption 2 dude people are talking to
me like i'll play the witcher 3 that's
got heart just like red dead i get it
but dude i don't know man i'm not really
into that fantasy [ __ ] you know red dead
redemption that was how life was back
then in gta 5. that's how life is right
now do it it is
i just don't know about the witcher but
i'm going to try it i'm going to try
these different games but grand theft
auto is just like so [ __ ] it's hard
it's hard for me you know i'm 41 and
it's hard for me and i play on twitch
come on down to flex avenue and join us
and people are like bro you're so bad
it's so hard to watch but dude i can't
help it man i learned i learned this
fast as fast as i learned
um
what the [ __ ] up with that hezbollah
guy
what what is he like three feet and 40
years old i don't even know can i even
say that
that three-foot guy that they're trying
to get to the ufc to fight another
three-foot guy
like dude you know what i mean like and
what's the what the [ __ ] this kid's just
sitting in first class with stacks and a
mask an adult mask on it's covering his
eyes
because he's so small and then and he's
just got stacks of whatever the [ __ ]
money this is
in this picture what's the deal with him
i don't know i i i don't know what what
does he what does he do what's his job
nobody you this is the time we live in
now you don't even need to have a job
you could just be a [ __ ] person that
looks a certain way and then get money
you know whether you're a [ __ ] hot
chick on tick tock dance in a [ __ ]
renegade renegade renegade or you're
just some [ __ ] short guy running
around acting like you're 40 years old
he is i guess then all of a sudden you
just get money remember in the 80s when
you had to actually do some [ __ ]
when you had to [ __ ] remember the 90s
when you had to [ __ ] like literally
like start a grunge band from the ground
up and it took [ __ ] 15 years before
you could start being like oh yeah
selling out a goddamn troubadour
now it's just
renegade renegade renegade renegade
all you gotta do is [ __ ] it's
unbelievable dude
what i do know is i made [ __ ] two
dollars on tick tock today
um
[Music]
so that's what's up oh we're 55 minutes
in wow that really flew by
huh
i don't know man
who knows anymore who knows anymore i'm
just [ __ ] dude i went out i got that
how many times can postmates [ __ ] up by
the way
percent of the time i ordered a burrito
they showed up with a [ __ ] empty bag
here you go it just had the sauce in it
i'm like bro
i didn't you don't even check it too
every time i pick it up i cause i don't
i let them leave i say leave it outside
of the thing sometimes they still knock
on the door or ring the doorbell it
literally says on my thing baby's asleep
don't ring or knock and they'll just
ding dong and i'm just you know just
leave it out there
[ __ ] and then i show up and it's just
like some kleenex and a goddamn
some [ __ ]
barks root beer
and i'm like what the [ __ ] dude and i
did no no burrito dude i got a [ __ ]
white bean salad and a burrito just the
white bean salad show up shows up
this is what happens when [ __ ]
are out there dancing a renegade on
tick-tock
and you get a career just for looking a
certain way
that's the end of civilization when you
get a job because you look a certain way
it's over
mod unless you're a model right
actor maybe if you need to fit the part
but like [ __ ] goddamn dude
whatever who cares who who even knows
anymore i gotta go i gotta go to the
bathroom so bad i think i have to stop
so we can cut this and i'll have to come
back and finish up because i gotta go
about them so bad i'm back dude i had to
go to the bathroom sorry i had to go
potty
i'm glad though because i while i was
doing i was going to the bathroom i
remembered this [ __ ] dude we had my
family over
uh
like my mom and my dad
and uh
they came over to eat
dinner and we had another friend of ours
here and calvin and kristen and
i i actually i haven't talked to my dad
about this yet and i want to talk to you
guys about this first because i don't
even know why but i think it'll be
[ __ ] funny because my dad listens to
this podcast and he's definitely going
to hear this but
like
so
we got pasta this is a [ __ ] minor
thing right but we got pasta
and uh i got three
angel hairs
i got spaghetti bolognese for kristen
and i got
um
a linguine in a pink sauce for me
pink sauce didn't show up it was red
sauce anyway got pissed it was maria's
italian kitchen you know the [ __ ]
story i told about it and they didn't
[ __ ] do the pink sauce got pissed but
it's all good i also got two capreses
and i got a [ __ ] salmon whatever i
got a shitload of food the most thing
that we had though was the angel hair
pasta right i was like you can't go
wrong with that the people are going to
like it my family's italian it's fine my
parents said they didn't care what we
were going to eat so fine so it all came
and i got the [ __ ] [ __ ] uh the
ingredient pink sauce for me they didn't
have a pink sauce and uh it had a red
sauce i was like i just put it in my
bowl and i brought it over to the thing
all this stuff was on the kitchen island
so i put it in the bowl i brought it
over to
the dining room and i see my dad
with
um
angel hair pasta okay
and then i see kristen bring her
spaghetti with meat sauce over to her
dining room table
then i leave to get up to get a drink
the only person at the dining room table
now is my dad with his angel hair pasta
okay
i
go get the drink i come back and i
notice in my dad's dish
is angel hair pasta
and some spaghetti with meat sauce right
now
the only person who had spaghetti with
meat sauce in their bowl was kristin
everyone else had angel hair pasta and i
had the linguine i noticed it and i
thought i must have not seen something
right he must have got it at the kitchen
island
whatever right
because the only other
explanation would be he was at the
dining room table alone and then
literally scooped
spaghetti with meat sauce out of
kristen's bowl and put it in his bowl
which is something that just
my dad would never do okay
so now i'm like well
[ __ ] maybe my dad
you know when people get older they just
start doing [ __ ] you know what i mean
like old dude old like when people get
really old that's when they just start
farting and you don't even know
if like they meant to do it or not but
you don't even question it right like
like like like a 78 year old man will
just be standing in like a tv room and
you're watching tv and he'll just be
like
and you'll just like won't even say
anything about it because you're like
well they're 78 right but so i'm like my
dad's not there yet that's 73 but maybe
he fi maybe that was the moment where he
was just like oh
pasta and put it in his [ __ ]
and we just gotta allow now we just got
to live by a different a set of
standards for dad right like oh we never
know
we never know what the [ __ ] he's going
to be thinking or doing or maybe he's
going to be that guy that's just
standing in the living room we're
watching the mets play and he's just
going to fart and we're just going to
like not even
mention it
so i go to bed uh that night um i forget
it and then kristen says
you know i think that
your dad
took some of my
spaghetti with meat sauce but it was so
weird because he didn't do it at the
kitchen island
the island in the kitchen he did it
already when we had already picked our
portions
and i don't know if and she said the
exact same thing i did she was like i
don't know if he did it because like
it he's just old and he just thought oh
whatever
or
if he
or what and i was like it's so unlike
him to be rude and just be like i want
that boss
like
and so i haven't asked him about it but
i'm going to ask him and i'm going to
keep you guys updated about this because
i want to know if my dad even knows he
did it he's probably not going to
remember and this is all going to be
[ __ ]
but i'm going to tell my mom about it
she's gonna laugh her [ __ ] ass off
and i asked my brother about it i was
like dude does that have dementia like
what's going on and my brother's like
maybe he just wanted it and thought [ __ ]
it and i was like man when you put it
that way it's less rude
and it's just like i don't know i just
wanted some but it was just so [ __ ]
weird it was weird though to have that
moment of [ __ ] dude is my dad now just
old as [ __ ]
he's 73 and he looks you know 67
65 he looks good
but like
i don't know i'm gonna ask and then you
guys are gonna know about it next time
i'm you know i should [ __ ] call him
next next next episode and ask him what
the [ __ ] he was doing with the thing i
should call him now
[ __ ] it i'm not gonna put him on the
spot like that
actually you know what i'm gonna [ __ ]
call him now
i'm gonna call him now
i'm gonna text him now and then see if
he
uh will pick up
i don't wanna uh
hi dad
i'm doing my podcast
and have a
question
can i call you
we can cut it out if you don't want it
on
okay waiting this should be good
uh although he's probably not going to
[ __ ] write back quickly although it
is only [ __ ] 9 p.m let's see if you
[ __ ]
or just call me or just call me
me
this is good in the meantime i should
have done this in the beginning of the
episode in the meantime i'm gonna um
what should we talk about
well he's probably [ __ ] watching
combat or something the show in 1950
dude my dad will watch the [ __ ] and
he'll be like you gotta watch his show
combat you gotta do it every i can't
wait christmas is coming up dude he's
gonna [ __ ] want to watch it's a
wonderful life and then after the chris
oh there he is
what's up
hey
oh you called me mobile always mobile
and not face time audio but it's okay
are you there you want me to call you on
facetime audio yeah i think so i'm going
to call you on facetime audio okay
okay all right he [ __ ] never does it
dude i say always call me on facetime
audio and he never does it
i mean never
it's so much clearer dude
[Music]
hey what's up way better dude how come
you don't ever call me on facetime why
don't you call me on facetime audio
because i didn't think i had to but you
know that you have to when i'm at home
i i didn't think i had to in this house
in this house what do you mean in this
in your house the house you're in now
oh
well yeah no oh got it okay in the other
house she thought it was another house
thing
yeah okay listen
so no i have a question for you
yeah for this you're on my podcast i
could cut it out if you don't want to be
whatever but it's not it's not anything
i don't think you'd care i just wanted
to say that but like okay so we ordered
the other night we ordered pasta i
remember we got it from maria's italian
kitchen and we all ate it and [ __ ] right
we were all together
and then and then uh i got i got
spaghetti bolognese for kristen and then
i got uh myself
spaghetti with red sauce it was supposed
to be pink sauce but it was red sauce
and then i got a bunch of angel hair
pasta right right and you got angel hair
pasta
okay okay so
all right just i'm telling you i'm not
asking you i'm telling you you got angel
hair pasta at the you got the angel hair
pasta at the actual
um
island the kitchen island right and then
you brought it over to the dining room
table and i was and i was there and i
was and i had my spaghetti in the red
sauce
and kristen brought her spaghetti with
the meat sauce over to her thing and
then when i looked over you i i like
looked away for a second maybe i got up
to get a drink and then i came back and
you had angel hair pasta and spaghetti
with meat sauce in your bowl
right okay what do you i i at this
moment i was like i didn't know what you
did i was like do you
did you did you just [ __ ] did are you
all of it was this the moment that you
become an old guy and didn't understand
that
that was not your pasta or did you just
where you just
i saw the bowl of pasta
yeah and i thought that was for all of
us oh
i took some of it from
and i understood after the fact that it
was kristen's bowl
[Laughter]
but i didn't know it at the time
all right that's the best possible
answer
that's the best way just i just took it
by mistake
that's that
but don't you know that we already had
the pasta on the kitchen island for
people and then we brought it to the why
would we bring it to a second location
so you could also serve yourself i
didn't know that
i didn't know that until after you told
me that oh i told you that
yeah okay
oh oh right now you mean right now okay
okay you told me the pasta was on the
table
and i didn't know that do you understand
that when i was back when that happened
i thought like oh [ __ ] my dad's an old
guy
i thought that this was just the moment
we were just gonna have to treat you
differently and you're just gonna be the
guy eating everybody's pasta and like
farting in the middle of the room
i was i was like i was like oh no
that's funny all right so you still
still got some years left with your
mental uh faculty
i can't go jesus
i guess so all right that's it i just
wanted
a mistake no that's okay i'd rather you
make a mistake than [ __ ] think every
pasta is your pasta
you thought i was just eating from
somebody else
i thought maybe you know you know when
guys you know like 85 90 year olds
you're just like they do they just do
[ __ ] and you're like oh just they're
gonna like they're just who they are
they're old
that's [ __ ] hilarious yeah
oh man
that's good that that that honestly i
could breathe easier now
[Laughter]
i can't believe you called me yeah well
because i was telling the story on my
podcast and i was like i'll find out and
get back i was like no you know what i'm
just gonna call
all right
i'll talk to you later all right see ya
all right there you have it dude my
dad's got a few more years with his
[ __ ] mental capacity
that makes me feel good
all right and let's and that's why we
call it
feel good podcast congratulations do you
see it all comes first full circle
it was the best possible scenario
when you're an addict and you're working
the steps they tell you hey don't
suppose [ __ ] that you don't know about i
was supposing that all of a sudden my
dad was gonna have dementia farting in
the living room while we were trying to
watch baseball when in actuality he just
made a [ __ ] absolutely moronic
mistake thinking that you would bring
the [ __ ]
pasta to a second location like it's a
kidnap victim
and and like have your way with it you
know unbelievable
well you guys um
like what else would you have a [ __ ]
kitchen island for if not to like serve
and we bring it back to the [ __ ]
dining room and he's serving himself
there too dude
she also took another container already
he was in a bowl dude i gotta call him
back after this all right you guys are
great uh thank you very much go to
crystallia.com and uh get that merch
support the show we love it hey guys
well that was the episode to catch the
rest of the episode and much
and many many more episodes head on over
to our
patreon.comcrystalia you get uh ad free
no commercials on our podcast and one
extra episode a month there's like nine
there now backlogged so if you sign up
now for only six dollars you can check
uh the last
catalog the back catalog that's patreon
only uh for the for congratulations um
and uh
yeah it's all sorts of extra [ __ ] there
so go check
patreon.comcrystalia thanks and bye
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
oh